[Music]
jennifer garner enjoys a relaxing
weekend getaway
absolutely as her ex ben affleck tied
the knot with jennifer lopez in vegas
the 50-year-old actress took to
instagram with a selfie looking carefree
while biking along the coast in lake
tahoe
looks like jen's visit was a peaceful
one here she is taking in the ocean
views and flying high on a paragliding
adventure
[Music]
it's nice to see garner living her best
life all while her ex-husband was over
in sin sitting making a big decision
and this
was my wedding
changing area
yup that's affleck in a glamorous
changing room right before saying i do
to jlo in an intimate ceremony at las
vegas little white chapel this is
affleck's second shot at love with j-lo
and second marriage
garner wed affleck in 2005 just one year
after he called off his engagement to
j.lo garner and affleck welcomed three
kids together violet seraphina and
samuel before finalizing their divorce
in 2018.
but now there's officially a new mrs
affleck it's exciting j.lo confirmed the
wedding news posting a makeup free pick
from bed and showing off her new blink
and fans got all the details on
benefit's big day over on her on the
j-lo newsletter the singer rocked two
gowns one stunning off-the-shoulder
long-sleeved lace gown by zouaira maraud
and another dress from a past movie
i feel
so excited you look gorgeous
[Music]
somebody's getting married
and benifer exchanged vows surrounded by
their closest friends and family
including jen's 14 year old emmy who
rode shotgun in their vintage cadillac
convertible my mom's just like she's
amazing and get this looks like the
blushing bride changed her last name she
signed off her newsletter writing with
love mrs jennifer lynn affleck it's just
a dream come true
[Music]
you